this is really funny just because it once
again sort of pierces the false notion that
all these right-wingers and from vis want
is to have transparency and conversation and
dialogue and exploring our differences in
a respectful way.
Donald Trump jr was booed off stage when it
was announced that he would not be taking
questions during a book tour event and there's
kind of almost like a recursive nature to
the way in which speech was curtailed.
It's very interesting.
Now the other element to this is that the
audience that did the booing is a generally
speaking, pro-Trump audience.
It was an audience at an event organized by
turning points USA.
This is the pro Trump group that sped spreads,
pro Trump propaganda on college campuses.
They have a couple of people, a Charlie corks
and Candace blow ins and or Owens I forget
and they're well known in the circuit.
They love Trump.
Trump loves them.
It's a whole scene, right, so Don jr shows
up at UCLA for this book tour event to promote
his book.
I guess technically it does count as a book
even though the writing can only be considered
writing in the most technical sense, the audience
is told there will be no Q and a and they
go crazy chanting Q and a and stuff like that
and ultimately shutting down the event and
Don jr having to walk off the stage.
Now, one more thing before we look at the
video and listen to the audio, you will hear
a woman's voice a pop up.
That is John Junior's new girlfriend.
As many of you may know, Don jr is now dating
Kimberly Guilfoyle who is a former Fox news
host.
She's been traveling with Dawn to his events
and being part of that, even though it's only
actually a bigger distraction if you saw the
appearance of Don jr on the view, I'm continually
getting into arguments with people while adding
nothing and then in would pop up or Kimberly
Guilfoyle talking over people in trying to
haphazardly defend Don jr.
It all just doesn't make any sense.
She's just traveling around a he, he's traveling
around with the former Fox news host who runs
interference for him.
Like it's all just extraordinarily weird.
Anyway, she's on stage as well.
Let's check out the first video
[inaudible] see what I mean?
And that's, that is the problem.
And the reason, oftentimes it doesn't make
sense to do the Q and A's, not because we're
not willing to talk about the questions because
we do now [inaudible] jacket with nonsense,
looking to go for some sort of sound bite.
You have people spreading nonsense spreading
hate to try to take over that room.
[inaudible]
you're not making your parents proud by being
rude and disruptive and discourteous to answer
the people around you so that they can hear
you.
Don't play, you don't play by the same rules.
Let me tell you something.
I bet you engage and go on online dating because
you're impressing no one here to get a date
in person.
How many people have you catfish?
So they are not pleased clearly with the lack
of a Q and.
A. How patronizing is it for Kimberly Guilfoyle
to tell the students that their parents wouldn't
like their behavior right now?
It is so funny in so many ways.
And on the one hand it's pathetic that he's
not going to do a Q and a right?
The, the whole thing with these TP USA events
is people get to ask questions and sometimes
the questions are adversarial, but sometimes
the questions are Brown nosing, but whatever
you're doing questions and they're not going
to do it.
So that's pathetic.
On the other hand, it's pathetic that anyone
thinks Don jr has anything interesting to
say that they would be all broken up, that
there isn't going to be a Q and a.
I mean, it's the blind leading the blind and
in the the the strictest sense.
And then the video continues.
Uh, and Don says, listen, we're okay with
Q and a in principle, but not when it's bad
faith or when people derail it or whatever.
And then you'll see them if you're watching
cut to another shot where the entire thing
just wraps early to resounding booze and they
just walk off stage
[inaudible] the furthest left is on a college
campus, right?
It doesn't happen that way where we're willing
to listen.
We're willing to listen.
[inaudible] so
TP USA is doing damage control because when
you hear the protests, these are not left
wing protesters, right?
These are right wing nationalist America firsters
pro Trumpers who want their Q and a.
So TPE USA is framing it as these are extremists.
This is just a wing of the right.
It is not representative of a mainstream Trump
supporter, whatever, guys.
I mean, have fun fighting about which contingent
of your movement was behind this.
But the big takeaway is that as soon as they're
not in an in an absolute safe space, they're
immediately terrified and triggered.
There was no big political message here behind
this protest, uh, of these supposedly extremists
in the audience.
This was some people who were mad that they
weren't going to get a chance to ask Don jr
questions.
There's no big political or philosophical
message and the dumb protest.
But notice how when Trump sr Donald Trump,
the president shows up at a sporting event
and people boo, he looks visibly shocked and
he's grimacing.
When Don jr shows up and people boo, they
just shut down the event.
After having his girlfriend lecture the crowd
about how their parents would be really displeased
with the way that they're behaving themselves.
Their protest doesn't even make sense, but
it's delightful to see their own side shut
down their speech when all they do is say
that it's the left that shuts down speech.
Don jr has made a speaking career and a book.
Actually a lot of the book is about this going
around saying the left shuts down dialogue.
The left doesn't want their ideas challenged.
The left doesn't want discussion.
The Duff Duff doesn't want to have to answer
to criticisms of their ideas.
Their followers go around saying the same
thing and what happens is that Don jr says,
no questions.
I'm the crowd shuts them down.
It's ironic in a sense, not that they have
any ability to see irony, but what it really
proves actually is the bad faith net nature
with which all of these political memes become
perpetuated and they're actually meaningless.
And we're going to talk about this on the
Friday show.
There's a question on the Friday show about
SJ W's.
What happened to SJWs?
The question is nothing ever happened to SJWs.
There were just, they became a popular target
of the right.
Um, and they do the extent that they reflect
a particular wing of the left.
They have existed for a long time and continue
to exist, but the right has moved on to other
things at this point.
In the same way, it's this irony of they've
been talking for so long about the left wants
to shut down debate and they don't want dialogue
and whatever.
And of course anecdotally you can find instances
of everything when it is the right that is
so heavily triggered by disagreements, by
having to defend their ideas by someone who
says, I'm not going to take questions.
And then shutting them down completely.
These people are pathetic and they will never
see the irony because they like the president
seem to lack some, I don't know, some switch
in their brain that allows them to see irony
and double standards.